[Música]
se vocês não se lembram o dia em que eu
recebi a medalha olímpica dentro do
estádio ninho do pássaro nos jogos
olímpicos de pequim em 2008
vocês não estão caminhando na curta
porque esse dia esse grande momento
nunca existiu
eu posso usar em dizer que poucas
pessoas sabem que no vale do aço tem uma
medalhista olímpica a medalha olímpica é
um marco na minha vida mas isso começou
lá atrás quando aquela criança ficava
brincando com seus coleguinhas na rua da
curva da ferradura ente moda e depois
através das aulas de educação física
aonde eu aprendi várias modalidades e me
apaixonei pela corrida pelo atletismo e
onde me levou a treinar no clube usipa
hause para fazer intercâmbio entre as
escolas do vale do aço para revelar
novos ataques e assim eu foi revelada
mas desde criança desde pequena eu
sempre gostei de esporte a minha família
em geral
eu me lembro uma vez que eu estava
assistindo os jogos olímpicos e eu vi o
brasileiro joaquim cruz correndo ele
ganhou a prova dos 800 metros e depois
ele pegou a bandeira e deu a grande
volta olímpica
eu achei bonita aquela cena fiquei
pensando um dia eu quero certo neta de a
medalha e paraolimpíada e da grande
volta olímpica foi treinando e me
dedicando e esforçando e depois de
alguns anos eu bati meu primeiro recorde
o recorde brasileiro nos 100 metros
rasos no rio de janeiro
em 99 eu bati o recorde de sula american
no 100 e 200 metros rasos bogotá na
colômbia e no mesmo ano eu fui vice
campeã pan americana em winnipeg no
canadá em 99 eu estava na melhor fase da
minha carreira de lucimar moura do vasco
que bateu o recorde sul americano com a
marca de 22 segundos 75 centésimos e da
boné tempo passa mas a vida do atleta
nem tudo são vitórias glórias
a gente passa por grandes desafios falta
da família
falta de patrocínio aquela pressão que
você tem que fazer resultado você está
treinando em fazer resultado e lesão a
lesão é pior de toda para um atleta
eu me lembro que no ano de 2000 teve
olimpíada de sydney e eu estava
lesionada nesse ano eu demorei a me
recuperar e quando fui fazer uma
competição para tentar o índice olímpico
nos 100 metros eu fiquei a quatro
milésimos de segundo que 4000º piscar de
olho não é nada mas na corrida é aquele
momento que reparar não querer mais
treinar mas eu não podia eu tinha que
ter fé acredita em deus porque eu tinha
um sonho na frente um objetivo na vida
em 2003 eu fui morar em são paulo onde
tive mais apoio no treinamento em
estrutura e 2004 eu realizei meu grande
sonho jogos olímpicos de atenas na
grécia
pra mim foi uma realização eu estava no
país aonde tudo iniciou os primeiros
jogos olímpicos da era moderna quando
pisei na pista passou o filme de toda
minha trajetória de uma das provas que
eu fui fazer além dos 100 200 que ocorre
com o revezamento 4 100 feminino é uma
prova coletiva do atletismo
aonde são quatro atletas cada uma com
recém metros e tem que passar o bastão
sucessivamente
nós corremos ficamos em nono lugar não
classificando mas só foi ter uma boa
classificação que é a primeira vez que o
revezamento feminino estava nos jogos
olímpicos mas depois de atenas
a gente começou a treinar mais a reunir
a fazer camping porque algumas meninas
não era da mesma região do mesmo estado
começamos a treinar a técnica da
passagem do bastão para deixar o bastão
cair para fazer uma corrida mais rápida
para ganhar tempo
fomos para uma competição em 2005 na
finlândia e ficamos em sexto lugar
já melhorou e melhorou nossa auto-estima
e sonhar com uma vaga olímpica para 2008
em 2008 o sonho realizado novamente
jogos olímpicos de pequim na china
eu fui para pequim com um só objetivo
chegar à grande final e brigar por
medalhas juntamente com meus colegas nos
estados unidos num só objetivo o
revezamento na olimpíada é dividida em
duas etapas semifinal onde são 16 países
correndo atrás de oito vagas
nós corremos classificamos ficam feliz
né primeira vez pelo resultado e ainda
depois deu tempo de tirar uma foto com
bolt ele estava lá na pista de
aquecimento
alguns dias atrás ele pôs fogo na pista
ele bateu dois recordes olímpicos e eu
estava presente divino tudo estádio veio
abaixo a bond é doido correu brincando
soltando olhamos adversários e eu não
poderia perder essa oportunidade né de
ti à tarde então essa foto pra casa
mas aí na segunda parte da etapa
no outro dia o dia da grande final
eu me lembro como hoje tá aqui ó fresco
na memória
nós acordamos
fomos tomar café depois em oração
juntamente com o novo treinador é hora
do almoço há uns anos cada um faz seu
quarto descansar e começar a se
concentrar e à tardinha saímos da vila
olímpica para o estádio
aqui tem seis é porque caso aconteça tem
que ter reservas e quando nós chegamos
no estádio ninho do pássaro
a má imagem atleta do brasil estava
faltando era grande favorita não é uma
medalha na prova do salto em distância
nós começamos a crescer nos preparar
depois de uma hora uma hora e meia fomos
chamados para entrarmos a pista
nesse intervalo a marca ganhou ela
estava lá dentro
comemorando e quando estava caminhando
para o meu setor
eu era segundo atleta a segunda mulher
pegou o bastão ocorria na reta oposta
naquela posição do brasil era melhor não
tinha para ninguém
durante 12 anos só de revezamento eu era
melhor eu estava caminhando e amava eu
passei a próxima era concerto também do
sol distância é do lado oposto
ela toda forma tinha ganhado a medalha
que eu tô boa sorte nossa
aquino repito dinha aquele pela força me
deu energia
eu bati no pé diz a lei
hoje eu vou fazer a melhor corrida da
minha vida
eu olhei pro estádio estava lotado
mercado
eu nunca tinha visto tanta gente de
olhos puxados está na china
eu queria ver um rosto familiar mas não
vi mas aí eu me preparei deu a largada
eu peguei um bastão
mas eu morri mas eu corri tanto que vão
das primeiras a passar o bastão
eu não vi ninguém
depois eu não tive uma visão boa que
começa a distanciar e são muitas menina
a troca de passagem de bastão eu comecei
a acompanhar pelo telão do estádio e
houve que estavam quase mandou próximo o
terceiro quarto lugar meu deus
córdoba não impede ninguém merece uma
posição 10 milésimos de segundo a gente
não ganha medalha de bronze nos jogos
olímpicos
foi terrível mas naquela noite
nós demos o nosso melhor fomos vitoriosa
por chegarmos ali acabou
fomos ao encontro do nosso treinador
toda chorando né
ele falou meninas parabéns vocês
correram muito mas a gente
nós queremos a medalha
acabou a olimpíada em 2009 eu ainda
participei de um mundial em berlim na
alemanha e no final do ano eu dei uma
parada
eu engravidei em 2010 eu me tornei mãe e
quando eu voltei a treinar em 2011
eu já não estava mais com aquela vontade
e dedicação esses penso na idade também
estava chegando também foram 25 anos
dedicado atletismo e sempre
representando o brasil esse mundo afora
retornei à ipatinga para ficar
definitivamente com a minha filha e meu
marido leoninos mais conhecido como caso
que conheci na pista da usiba e de vez
em quando ficava em casa pensando em
títulos
bate recordes viaje por esse mundo afora
com esse vários lugares cultura
me formei em educação física tudo
através do atletismo através do esporte
mas é lamentável que tenha encerrado a
minha carreira não ter ganho a medalha
olímpica é um belo dia eu estava em casa
e um amigo me enviou o link onde estava
escrito que uma das atletas da rússia
estava com suspeita de doping
eu nem me lembrava mais que a rússia
tinha ganho eu só me lembrar do nosso
quarto
eu tinha passado oito anos e também não
têm direito ao saque milena meio
desconfiado as coisas né
mas aí o comitê olímpico foi
investigando investigando e descobriu
que a rússia estava com o esquema de dop
generalizada
eu me lembrei da fala da thaissa quando
nós acabamos de correr pra sair da pista
nós temos que passar pela zona mista na
entrevista ao canal de televisão e até a
isso diz o seguinte se esperava medalha
mas se deus não permitir desta vez é
porque tem algo maior para nós mais pra
frente nós
existe deus é fiel e durante os jogos
olímpicos no rio de janeiro aqui no
brasil saiu a nota oficial que o brasil
é daria a medalha de bronze
eu estava na minha casa juntamente com
minha filha assistindo televisão na sala
vi no atletismo e começa a noticiar
aliás a minha vida mudou nós somos
medalhistas
eu comecei a chorar a chorar
a minha filha falou mamãe porque você
está chorando eu falei filha mãe é
medalhista olímpica ela mais coisas e só
parou de treinar se no corre mais se
instalar na televisão eu falei filha
a história é longa depois de uma noite
curta eu falei com alguns minutos
eu agradeci a deus e fiquei pensando em
todos aqueles esforço treinamento camp
durante quatro anos
tudo valeu a pena e ficou oculto por
oito anos
às vezes a nossa vitória se mostra curta
e temos que dar errado detalhes
eu recebi a medalha no rio em março de
2017 depois de nove anos em uma
cerimônia realizada pelo comitê olímpico
brasileiro
muitas pessoas nem chegam falando perde
- mas você perdeu a primeira coisa
dinheiro e reconhecimento e prestígio
mas o que eu peço se realmente foi um
prazer de realizar meu sonho de subir ao
pódio dentro do estádio ninho do pássaro
ver a bandeira do brasil hasteada editar
grande volta olímpica como eu sempre
imaginei quando era criança eu via
joaquim isso perdi nos roubaram não
volta mais
acabou
quando eu voltei para a china com a
medalha foi recebida no aeroporto por
algumas autoridades da cidade de tio
moto de patinga familiares amigos e o
clube usipa onde eu fui revelado que fez
a questão de eu sentir a mesma emoção
como fosse há nove anos atrás quando a
gente do porto
a gente dizia tá roberto alguns
velocidade mas o que eu quero passar
realmente press
não vale a pena ganhar de qualquer jeito
de forma ilícita
as regras do esporte nos ensina respeita
as regras ea entender bem e isso e hoje
eu sinto e hoje eu posso estar aqui no
pescoço com o mundo okur mundo obrigado
[Aplausos]